so we've now had an update from number
10
about the prime minister's meeting in
brussels let's go straight to our deputy
political editor
sam coats who's in downing street and uh
to be
fair a downbeat update is how you might
phrase this sam
that's right after three hours of talks
a pessimistic statement just released
by number 10 with one big decision let
me read you and senior number 10 source
the prime minister and ursula vonderline
had a
frank discussion about the significant
obstacles which remain in the
negotiations
very large gaps remain between the two
sides and it is still
unclear whether these can be bridged the
prime minister and ursula on the line
agreed to further discussions over the
next few days
between their negotiating teams the
prime minister does not want to leave
any route to a possible deal
untested the prime minister and this is
the key bit and ursula of underline
agreed that by sunday a firm decision
should be taken about the future of the
talk so there you have it there appears
to be a deadline
another deadline for brexit in four days
time
after which point boris johnson could
press the button on no trade deal
preparations